what if anything did you do differently
in terms of pursuing your acting career
well i've always
i've always been really
i've always
been really independent you know and
i've never imagined not working i've
worked from the earliest time i can
imagine i
come from you know
parents who
worked until they literally couldn't
anymore you know i
never never imagined myself
having to
explain my job or justify my job but i
did you know and i am independent and i
see myself as independent
and strong-willed and i had to
bargain every time i'd get a script it
would be
you know
i thought you weren't taking another job
i'd always say are you kidding me that's
crazy i have to work i support my family
you know when i moved out to la i'd get
a check for
you know a gig six hundred dollars or
something i'd save half for me send half
to my family
you know i
i kept having to justify taking work by
saying i'm supporting my parents you
know i'm supporting my sister i'm
supporting my family i have to work
and he would say you don't have to work
kid let me take care of you my woman
doesn't have to work
and that sounds really sweet and really
romantic in in some way but it became a
real fight you know every time
i got a script it was what kind of you
know how i was dressing what kind of
behavior i'd have what how did i have a
sex scene and then i started saying no i
won't take the sex scenes or
you know i'll take the part where i
don't play
you know that kind of character or then
i started minimizing the kinds of
kissing scenes that i had and eventually
i had to change the wardrobe
that i could have in in the movie i
couldn't have a
couldn't have a sex scene but that all
you know was
it didn't happen all at once of course
it was little thing after a little thing
after little thing and eventually
i found myself
pushing as many scripts off my desk as i
could
picking the ones that had minimal makeup
dress con as conservative as possible
finding ways to
minimize the scenes i had where i had a
romantic involvement of any kind it was
just it was a constant battle a
negotiation
so let me take you back did you
as a result of your discussions with mr
depp about moving in did there come a
time that you did move in with him
objection leading
overruled thank you
yes
please
and
let me ask you this
you've talked about pen top we've heard
a little bit about penthouse
appointments and and sweets or could you
just explain to the jury
the
uh different places that mr depp had in
los angeles and what they were called
just so we have some context here when
we're going through all this
it's a little
confusing i imagine um he had about i
think four or five
mansions in this beautiful
like you know border of beverly hills
and west hollywood
and they were all in a cul-de-sac
and we called it tweeter
because that was the name of this street
and they're five houses i think five
houses it could be four all
you know effectively he had the whole
street
then he had about five penthouses
downtown
on the same floor of the eastern
columbia building which you've heard
about the ecb
and sweetzer was
you know johnny's
kingdom
uh one of those houses was like a whole
house was his man cave it was a studio
and it was where he made music and hung
out um
and we spent some time in there but that
was effectively johnny's
you know
place and then there was the the
downtown places and they were
effectively empty saved for some
furniture and one of johnny's friends
isaac
who you met
and he lived there um
at some point before
johnny and i eventually decided to move
in together let me just stop you there i
just want to make sure we're clear are
we talking about the penthouses or we're
talking about sweet sir
isaac lived in the penthouses
the rest of them were about pretty much
empty and
my best friend um
who i was very very very very close to
uh
went through a breakup and he very
kindly
uh insisted on moving her into this
penthouse and of course she said no for
the first few times but he insisted and
said they were empty and he would love
to have her move down there and
he
very kindly moved my best friend
downtown probably rocky yeah
rocky pennington but the problem is it's
like
30 45 minutes from west hollywood where
my place was which we call orange